soberanía estabilidad y seguridad las
tres palabras que resumen la reunión de
varios líderes del medio oriente y el
presidente francés emmanuel marco en
bagdad la capital avanza y francia sigue
siendo un apoyo para irak para completar
la guerra contra el terrorismo y
garantizar la estabilidad y la paz en la
región al mismo tiempo francia es un
socio económico y comercial que nos
apoya en operaciones de reconstrucción
al papá entre los asistentes estuvieron
el presidente de egipto el rey de
jordania el emir de qatar el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de turquía y los
jefes de gobierno de kuwait y emiratos
árabes unidos el presidente francés
señaló la importancia de la cumbre para
la estabilidad de la región son act
social esta conferencia de fundamental
fijará las condiciones para la soberanía
la estabilidad de irak en la región con
todos sus vecinos y socios establecerá
un marco de cooperación para luchar
juntos contra el terrorismo pero también
para llevar a cabo proyectos de
desarrollo económico y respuestas reales
a los desafíos de la región económica de
rd pons decidió de la región uno de los
temas principales fue la lucha contra el
terrorismo y la seguridad de la región
irán fue enfático en decir que el gran
culpable de la inseguridad es eeuu
los estadounidenses no traen paz ni
seguridad a la región más bien fueron el
principal factor en la inseguridad ya
que este problema se puede ver y sentir
en varios países de la región el
al finalizar la reunión irak se mostró
de nuevo con un mediador clave en la
región y aunque hubo dialogo entre
rivales como arabia saudita eran y yemen
y líbano no hubo soluciones concretas
para bajar la atención entre dichas
naciones